il y a plus moi qui peut dire il y a
plus Mo encore une langue assez bonne
pas toujours
[Musique]
juste j'ésiterai jamais d'en parler on
parler jamais assez de résistance
[Musique]
jamais de ça il y a il y a 60 ans
maintenant la vie n'était pas ce qu'elle
est
maintenant j'étais
fanatique ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui on
voit des là qui sont fanatiques on
l'était nous parce que si j'avais pas
été fanatiqueura pasit ce que j'ai
fait c'était quand Mme était quand même
des à cette
épo j'ai jamais voulu marcher au P bon
c'est une question de tempérament c'est
comme ça pu toujours maintenant je
marche pas au pas 18 ans 15 ans c'était
une une Guer de jeune en fin de compte
parce que pour prendre de tel risque il
fallait être jeune on était des
terroristes cétait écrit d'ailleurs on
était des
terroristes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ici on voit personne mais auparavant ça
grouillait on était on était combien 300
à peu près dans le dans le dépôt oui oui
tout c'est partout il y a des gens qui
travaillent en
38 300 personnes il y pas de TGV ça
roulait pas 200 à l' mais ça
fonctionnait de tous les côtés les
machines chantaient quand elles étaient
sous
pression des bruit c'était
sensationnel
avec le Front populaire qui nous avait
donné aussi des certains acquis comme
les congés payés encore que nous SNCF on
avait déjà des congés payés mais on
avait pas les congés queon a eu après il
avait donc déjà les congés les 40h les
40h c'était on a connu une période euh
réellement de joie de
plaisir j'aimais prendre le charbon
mettre au feu j'aimais voir ce feu dans
les
foyersyz voilà le virus et puis j'imis
j'aimis la ligne j'aimis la route mon
père m'avait emmené tout gamin sur la
machine en tant que il m'avait emmené en
tant que spectateur je devais avoir 14
ans 15 ans j'avais été à Saint-Germain
j'avais été à viillon avec lui à les
retour j'avais couché dans les
dortoirs voyez j'avais déjà ce virus de
la SNCF et pour rien au monde j'aurais
voulu faire un autre métier ah les
roulants les roulant la machine c'était
ça classait tout le monde ça classait
tout le monde parmi la la population C
d'ambux d'ailleurs le gars qui était qui
était mécanicien et ça ça se voyait
parce que les tous avaient les yeux
cernés par les yeux cernés par la poudre
de charbon qui le je autour des yeux
autour de la bouche c'était c'était la
marque de
fabrique et bien les mécaniciens chez
nous ici c'était les sénateurs ah bon
ils avaient des bonnes payes parce que
ils étaient au kilomètres à
l'économie des critères hein et puis
c'était des maîtres
hein c'était des chefs les viux gr
mécano surtout par la pilis rchant oh là
là là là mais tout droit hein ça ah ça
déragait pas hein ou là les vieux
disaient ma machine ma
machine mon compagnon mon chauffeur ma
femme je suis resté 7 ans avec le même
mécanicien oui il y avait des liens
profond mécaniciens et chauffeurs n'en
continuent pas moins d'accomplir leurs
tâches conscients et fiers de leur
métier d'homme mais l'exemple de
l'esprit d'équipe deux hommes une seule
pensée le devoir
faut pas oubligier dans nos ateliers de
SNCF c'était des des des très grands
professionnels qu'on avait comme comme
ouvrier toutes les professions ajusteurs
outilleurs les tourneurs les fraiseurs
tous ceux qui travaillaient sur les
machine outil tous ceux qui faisaient
les soudures la soudure ou le montage le
démontage les révisions et cetera il
avais des locomotives très puissantes
150000 traîner des trains de munera de
1500 1600 1700
tonnes il fallait pas venir habiller en
blanc hein fallait pas venir habiller en
blanc on était on était en bleu puis on
était on nétait noir que comme des
cochons hein c'était non les cochons
sont pas noirs il
son on on était sale c'était la graisse
c'était la poussière c'était c'était
tout c les machines puis là-dessous les
machines qui mien qu'es sont chaudes que
qu'ell fument là-bas qu'est-ce qu'on
prend he vous savez une locomotive c'est
un un ensemble qui est chaud
150° une goutte
d'huile qui tombe qui vous tombe sur
votre bleu il pénétrait tout le bleu et
puis si vous tombez sur la main il vous
brûlait le travail éénuant c'était pas
de conduire la machine c'était de de
faire du gaz de faire de la vapeur avec
de l'eau et du charbon dans la chaudière
ça c'était exténuant parce que pour
aller à
viignnon j'ai eu brûlé 7 tonnes de
charbon avec une mauvaise
machine la CF je crois qu'il faut
d'abord rappeler qu'elle est toute jeune
puisquelle a été créée au 1er janvier 38
par la fusion de compagnie privée bon
donc la si n'existe pas encore comme
culture unifiée et on dira d'ailleurs
que la guerre sera l'occasion de serrer
les coups donc de fabriquer de de
d'amplifier ce début de culture
d'entreprise SNCF c'est un milieu qui av
un esprit Corporation important il non
pas du corporatif qui est nettement
différent VO mais un esprit de corps VO
il ça s toujours soudé tenz il y avait
une démarche et nous étions formés pour
ça hein il faut bien voir les choses en
face euh les écoles d'apprentissage on
était les meilleurs les plus beaux
évidemment bien sûr c'était logique
parce qu'on était jeune nous étions les
cadets du rail donc nous étions plein
d'allégresse et nous apprenions notre
travail avec confcience pour remplacer
les les enchens qui allaient partir vous
comprenez on était
Chemino fils de cheminau Petitfils de
cheminau et puis l'électricité voilà je
voulais faire l'électricité voilà donc
j'avais décidé de rentrer à la SNCF et
c'était un genre de tradition familiale
on me voyait chemis on n'a jamais laissé
un train en route on était obligé
d'aller au bout on était quand même fier
d'être de la
maison pourquoi parce que tu étais tu
étais le plus considéré puis c'était
fait un peu c'était fait à la à la
manière militaire he c'était la
hiérarchie la discipline qu' attacha
autour de tout ça c'était un peu comme
l'armée c'était oui juin 1940
après la Pologne la Hollande et la
Belgique Hitler lance ses armées contre
la
France le pays est écrasé en moins d'un
mois c'est la
débacle près de 2 million de prisonniers
de guerre sont conduits en captivité en
Allemagne parmi eux 35000
[Musique]
cheminau président brin fait appel au
maréchal Pétin son premier acte est de
demander l'armistice le 18 du mois un
général du nom de degou lance un appel
depuis Londres pour continuer le
combat le 22 Pétin signe
l'armistice l'occupation
commence premièrement c'est un militaire
et à cette époque là on était quand même
je dirais pacifiste on était pas
militariste la droite avait pas
digéré avait pas digéré
le la prise de position la prise de
contrôle de la France en 36 par le Front
populaire la droite a jamais digérer ça
il préférait hicl au Front
populaire et ils avaient fait leur choix
il a dissou la République dont il était
le représentant symbolique he pour en
faire un État français he c'est une
révolution tion de palais mais c'était
une
révolution un traite de première nature
quoi
hein j'ai toujours regretté qu'il a pas
été fusillé la Maréchal nous voilà non
c'était h de question et maréchal il m'a
pas vu bon c'est tout la grande majorité
des Français à 90 % il criait vive Pétin
faut pas se pleurer faut pas dire le
contraire et tous ceux qui disent bah
moi j'ai entendu l'appel du Général ne
ça me semble assez curieux parce que
comme au mois de juin l'app 18 juin il y
avait la moitié de la France toute la
partie nord qui était sur les route de
l'Exode en dehors d'un poste Galen je
pas comment on pouvait prendre la radio
de
londrmiss
mon Général
monieur
généralouver l'article 13 de la
convention d'armistice spécifie que le
réseau ferroviaire national est mis
entièrement à la disposition des
autorités militaires de
l'occupant il est notifié au chemin
français qu'ils sont soumis au rigueur
de la loi allemande qui prévoit le plus
souvent en cas de nonaboration les travx
forcés ou la peine de
[Musique]
mort va jouer ce jeu cette règle du jeu
elle ne l'aurait pas joué elle aurait
été tenté de dire de saboter cette règle
du jeu le directeur général le benneré à
plusieurs reprises expliqué qu'au fond
il valait mieux garder le manche et
sacrifier une partie de l'activité
formellement au besoins de l'occupant en
ayant en gardant le manche on pouvait
préserver au fond d'abord une partie de
ressources ferroviaires pour les besoins
civils ravitaillement euh et puis
préparer je dirais aussi la près-gerre
la reconstruction la libération comme il
y avait les prisonniers il y avait un
manque de personnel il fallait réparer
l'outil de travail il fallait
transporter les Allemands avaient besoin
de minerais avaient besoin de l'acier et
cetera donc ils ont mobilisé le maximum
de personnel pour remettre en
route l' ti de travail c'est-à-dire la
le chemin de fer et puis par la suite on
a été bon on a été versé là où
c'était le plus important pour pour les
Allemands
[Musique]
quoi alors les Allemands ben c'était
pour le r tour de piste
là il fais leur tour de piste il
surveillé pass que VO toujours il avait
un grand un professeur luiailleurs il
parlait un français impeccable ch avec
lui
quoiit des tours de Pit comme ça c'était
des des chefs de dépô chef d'entretien
qui dirigeit mais sous l'gide quand même
disons de la direction allemande des
banov comm on disait c'est la gare c'est
banov il y avait aucun coin où il n'y
avait pas un
banof aucun coin il dirigeait tout
complètement on avait notre stade qui
était juste devant le centre
d'apprentissage nous avait donné des des
des shorts un maillot tout ça quelqu son
son puis bon c'était autour de PIST
marché au por devant les banuf qu'on
appelait les banuf c'était l'occupation
des chemineau allemands pour défiler là
il fallait démarrer au P chantant puis
on m'a dit et si tu tu te démarres pas
normalement comme tout le
mondeas mon pied dans le cul c'est ce
que j'ai eu droit devant tout le monde
devant les Allemands qui sa ce qu'a fait
et j'ai pas démarré au pas j'ai pas
voulu et j'ai pas marché au pas malgré
le coup de P dans le que on avait par
obligation l'obligation de descendre du
trottoir pour laisser passer l'allemand
sur le trottoir
ouais c'est vrai alors vous savez que
bon quand on a quand on a 50 ans on
évite de sortir mais quand on a 20 ans
on apprécie pas
quoi on subissait la loi allemande
c'était la Gestapo qui était là la
police française évidemment qui faisait
la police mais pour l'Allemagne pour les
allemand et les arrestations il y avait
tout c'était déjà commencé tout cela il
suffisait qu'il y ait des opposants ils
étaient arrêtés en voiture fermez les
portes s'il vous plaît quand on a 18 ans
et qu'on a quelque chose dans le ventre
et bien on se dit mon pays est occupé il
n'a aucune raison d'être occuper il faut
à tout prix se débarrasser de l'occupant
chez les apprentis on était tous contre
les Allemands quoi
hein bon
euh ça sortait du fond de des familles
on est rester comme des
imbéciles je suis rentré au dépôt
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire et c'est là que
j'ai dit B on va leur faire des petites
vacheries si je vous dis oh tu sa pas ce
soir on va se marer on va aller faire un
petit coup de machin je sais pas on va
casser la vitre hein bon ben ça ù ça
vous intéresse hein de faire quelque
chose ou ça vous intéresse pas si ça
vous intéresse pas vous me dites bah va
donc toi puis c'est tout puis si ça vous
inér on y va tous les de qu'est-ce qu'on
va faire Puin qu'est-ce qu'on fait après
tiens bah ça y est c'est parti qui bah
c'est ça le le le le problème puis une
fois que c'est parti bah c'était ben on
recherche à faire quelque
[Musique]
chose le le 14 juillet le 11 novembre
c'est rassemblé pu aller chanter la
Marseillaise b La Marseillaise ça me
branche pas tellement mais pour nous
c'estit quelque chose d'important faut
le repasser dans son contexte vous voyez
et là allez et alors entouré par les
Allemands qui étai qui après nous nous
foulit en tirant il TI en l'air
quelquefois ils ont tiré dedans bon ben
c'était pas noodin comme manifestation
c'était vraiment pour s'opposer voyez le
11 novembre on prend cette date
commémoration de l'Armistice pour
organiser un arrêt de travail de 10
minutes c'est pas long 10 minutes mais
il a on lui donne un caractère spécial
les on sollicite les gens de rester à
leur poste de travail sans bouger on va
respecter 10 minutes de
silence à sa place alors évidemment on a
fait sonner les sirènes on a fait sonner
les locomotives pour à 11h alerter les
gens et tout le monde s'est arrêté on a
eu un arrêt ça a été très
impressionnant un atelier où on
travaille il y a du bruit et cetera puis
d'un seul coup paf un silence de mort
c'était le cas de dire un silence de
mort
et le mouvement a donc été très
largement suivi et
réussi on considéit que le le le point
essentiel si on voulait arriver à à
manifester notre dité à l'occupant
c'était déjà la
propagande propagande anti naaz
anti-allemande entioccupant parce que
ils se livrai leur propagande national
socialiste al c'était là notre premier
notre premier souci nous faisions des
inscriptions sur les murs sur les
locomotives sur partout où on pouvait on
faisait des inscriptions on avait un
journal
l'avant-garde qu'on pouvait diffuser on
éditait des tractes à diffuser dans les
boîte à lettres ou un collet vous voyez
dans sur un poteau sur n'importe quoi
voyez dans un endroit mais on
visiblebles pour tout le monde elle m'a
demandé de faire ça bah voyez tout à
fait spontanément j'ai dit oui et puis
je sais pas les événements te pouss au
derrière il il t'oblige la vie elle est
comme ça on bançait des tractes pour
appeler à la résistance pour appeler à
si mais je me rendais pas compte que
j'avais déjà deux enfants moi on disait
à personne personne ne connaissait notre
activité
clandestine c'était par prudence d'abord
peut-être pas toujours par méfiance mais
surtout par prudence parce que il
fallait éviter de bavarder il fallait
éviter que les que de des tiers sachent
ce qu'on pouvait faire et qui les
faisait on savait très bien qu'à
l'époque que transporter par exemple un
paquet de tract c'était équivalent à la
mitraillette il y avait pas dans le
compte pour les Allemands pour les nazis
il y avait pas de différence si vous ce
qui pris à transporter des armes ou des
traines c'était le même compte pour
eux nous étions 40 millions de
Français à cette époque làà il y a eu 5
millions de dénonciations la
guesto vous voyez le
pourcentage
mais chaque wagon pas possède une
étiquette deson des départ et
destination bon et bien combien au
départ changeait les
étiquettes si bien que ce qui devait
aller en Allemagne ça partait bordau ou
ailleurs et puis un vagon qui avait rien
dedans se retrouvait en Allemagne vous
voyez bon ça ça peut paraître rien mais
c'était énorme ça c'était énorme voyez
et celui qui faisait ça en général il
faisait spontanément nappartenait pas un
groupe par contre il artait pris il
risquit sa peau exactement comme
n'importe qui bon par exemple il fallait
remplacer resserrer les tampons rasser
les l planché bon on rass rien du tout
on mettait un espèce de truc sur la sur
le à la place de l planché il y avait
pas de lâ planché les tampons mettaient
un clou une pointe disons pour le serrer
un peu bon de façon que le visiteur
quand ça ressort il voille que ça a été
fait quoi c'était le sabotage ça c le
sabotage et on dormait dans dans les
wagons bien
souvent on faisait souvent la sieste
dans les wagons plutôt que de les
réparer VO si donc où il y a si c'était
si c'était comme ça he c'était pas comme
ça sur les machines à vapeur évidemment
quoi supposons supposons alors si vous
ouvrez cette cette cette boîte là céta
une boîte si vous ouvrez ça et vous avez
vous ça ça vous découvre le le la roue
la roue la fusée de la roue qui est au
bout et c'est c'est l'organe sur lequel
porte les coussinés et qui sont huilés
de manière à ce que ce que ça agisse que
le contact soit soit normal quoi mais si
vous si vous Z ça et que vous levez le
boîte et que vous mettez gentiment une
poignée de sable et que vous refermez la
la boîte tranquille bien au bout de 5 km
le
le le le le coussinet qui
là-dessus sera grippé et faudra arrêter
la machine il faudra remplacer les cieux
pour faire retourner faireajuster la
roue et le remettre en place tout ça ça
prend toujours une journée une grosse
journée mais il faut pas le faire trop
souvent parce que quand ça arrive une
fois deux fois il regarde les G les gars
qui tournent regarde qu'est-ce qui se
passe sont pas idiot hein
malheureusement et quand on a fait une
fois par là mais il faut trouver un
autre système hein ù faire plus loin
ailleurs pour pas faire reporter le
soupçon sur une équipe ou sur un
gar ici c'est le modèle réduit d'une 231
g des
pacifiques une bielle n'est pas
réversible un de piston n'est pas
réversible on pouvait pas prendre le
côté gauche pour mettre au côté droit
alors quand on fait sabotage C toujour
toujours du côté droit toujours du même
côté al on avait choisi le côté droit
pour que partout ça se fasse pareil et
qu'on trouve plus de pièces de rechange
vous voyez c'était c'était la technique
on fait un peu tous la même chose
d'ailleurs mais sans
organisations moi j'ai pas de j'ai pas
connu d'organisation à cette époque ça
existait mais on le savait pas moi je le
savais pas et mais il y avait quand même
une idée une comment une
orientation qui était donnée sans sans
sans qu'on sache quoi je crois que les
plus beaux sabotages ce sont ceux qui se
sont fait comme
ça à la
saette le but c'était de retarder le
plus possible la production la sortie
des wagons parce que c'était dans les
wagonsù j'étais et puis dans les dépôts
c'était la sortie des des
[Musique]
machines bah il montait il passait des
gens dans les dans les wagons ils
ouvraient les wagons il les passai il
les mettaient au milieu des au milieu
des ballots au milieu des des caisses au
milieu comment que ça se passe là à
calis comment avait ben voilà il montait
dans les trains alors il y avait il y
avait certains service il y avait
l'exploitation qui faisait son qui
faisait passer dégâts il y avait
l'attraction il faisait paser dégâts
vous voyez c'est on était pas tout seul
j'ai jamais fait d'éclat moi bon il un
gars passé bon ben viens avec moi monte
sur la machine on t'emmène il y avait
deux solutions un type tout seul on
pensait équiper en cheminau sur la
machine
hein à condition de de circuler la
nuit quand le mec le chauffeur mettait
du charbon dans la locomotive a une
lueur quiilluminait tout le ciel hein
bon euh donc on mettait une
barche alors dans la barche on pouvait
mettre un type sur le charbon euh
c'était
facile mais quand il en avait pig il
fallait les mettre dans le tind cette
partie là c'est le tinder qui comporte
la réserve d'eau pour la locomotive bien
sûr et le charbon bien évidemment il y
avait des tendair aménager de façon à
faire passer le courrier et des
passagers clandestins qui soient
résistant ou
[Musique]
juif
une fois avec la 141 P48 et ben j'ai
fait j'ai fait
l'imbécile je l'ai saboté ma machine je
savais qu'il y avait des trains
allemands qui étaient derrière nous ce
jour-là et j'ai dit comment on pourrait
bien faire pour
pouvoir les retarder il y avait pas 36
solutions j'ai démonté j'ai dévissé un
frein de tiroir je savais que le tiroir
allait se dérégler et allait [__]
machine en panne ça fait que j a fait il
y avait deux trains allemands qui
allaient qui allaient sur le sur le le
littoral qui allait dans le Midi et bien
on les a retardé de je les ai retardé de
3h mon mécano il savait pas que c'était
moi qui ah il m'a dit les salops il nous
il nous l'ont ah je dis oui il y en a un
qui a saboté la machine a quelqu'un
ouais je sais bien mais tu veux faire
j'avais pas le choix si je monte sur une
autre machine saboter une autre machine
euh et si je me fais prendre
mais si je suis en train de travailler
après la mienne j'avais toujours une
burette d'huile personne peut rien me
dire le soir je suis en train de
travailler après ma machine
oui j'ai honte j'ai honte d'avoir saboté
ma machine parce que j'étais tellement
minutieux c'est un réveil ma machine la
ma machine
c'était c'était ma vie c'était ma vie
c'était c'était mon outil de travail et
j'ai saboté mon outil de
travailne mêté fusillé en mars 42
c'était le secrétaire national des
ch je crois que jusqu'à ce
moment-là on avait pas très bien compris
que les civils pouvaient faire la guerre
il y avait 500000 cheminau en gros sur
500000 français
[Musique]
euh on peut dire motivé
500000 français qui rendent service aux
autres qui sont fait pour ça qu'on a
formé pour ça et puis on fusille un des
leurs comme ça parce que c'était le
secrétaire général et puis qui refusait
de donner les comptes à la police mais
on ça une réaction systématique chez les
cheminit une grosse erreur
psychologique les Allemands ont fait
avec la complicité de
[Musique]
pétinin il a un mai qui s'est créé
au-dessus à Bonneville en de savoir on
est rentré dans ce Maqui et là j'ai fait
connaissance du responsable de la dfttp
et je suis rentré au
FTP et puis bon après j'ai fait
j'ad dire au parti communiste en 43 mois
de septembre ouis c'est t des
communistes presque tous tous les
responsables presque tous des
communistes je rentr au FTP j'ai pas
signé de contrat j'ai pas signé de
contrat alors je demandé à quoi ça
consistait dit bon bah c'est des groupes
de combat et de sabotage alors
sabotageah dit toi tu nous rentris bien
service parce que par exemple comme tu
électricien bon dans les ateliers il y a
un temps de que tu peux provoquer qui
vont arrêter des machines pendant
longtemps qui vont arrêter des ponts
roulants qui vont arrêter tout ça
pendant longtemps sans que pour autant
on puisse prendre des otages parce que
ça sera une
panne bon ah ben ça je peux le faire et
exct je pouvais le faire c'était mon
métier et moi je suis arrivé ici pour
prendre reprendre en main le
commandement de ces groupe et puis
activer le les combats de la résistance
quoi j'organise
la moitié du Jura au point de vue FTP je
reprends ce qui était ce qui
existait on était 150 au maximum il y
avait 40 types d'or qui roulit au
ravitaillement au renseignement qui
roulent aller chercher
les all les contacts les liaison
s'arrêta pas avant que les Anglais
débarquent ils avaient envoyé des pour
étudier le problème des la vingtaine de
déraillements que MGA avait provoqué ici
les explosifs ça jamais été des moyens
de faire des
r par contre le déboulonnage des reils
déboulonnage avec orientation de l'avir
qu'elle continue pas en ligne droite
parce que un train qui est lancé à 80 à
l'heure même à 50 à l'heure il va tout
droit même si il manque un bout de voix
hein c'est ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
alors que si la voie le dirige à côté il
il reste pas
dessus c'est nous qui avons mis cette
technique là au point eux nous envoyé
des explosifs pour qu'on les fasse
sauter c'était à côté du
problème mon bureau était là c'était une
table sur laquelle quand on jugeait on
mettait un drapeau tricolore et que nous
prononcions la sentence au nom de la
Résistance française ici c'est le
français qui nous a fait le plus de tort
enfin le français le le [__] quoi le
le milicien le celui qui pour de
l'argent je vous ai dit que j'avais un
gars qui avait délancé pour de paquets
de
cigarettes on a tout vu on a tout vu on
a tout vu c'était pas le tout de faire
des Raay train de faire des railles et
des trains le problème c'était de pas
tomber or on sait parfaitement qu'en
multipliant les attaques pli les chances
de
tomber on avait des groupes très
très petit 6 7 on éta armé jusqu'au dent
armé jusqu'au dents on avait fusil
mitrailleur bezooka fusil bon grenade on
été organisé comme une armée régulière
pas de problème pas de problème bon
c'est vrai que c'était pas pareil parce
que on pouvait bon on était quand même
dans la clandestinité
bon les ordes arrivaient des fois bon
mais
enfin ça se passait bien en général
j'avais un groupe he bon je rassemblais
le groupe sabotage la nuit enfin tout ça
voilà sabotter ligension sabuté
euh les transformateurs enfin tout ça on
a fait ça on allait casser les rails on
all démontter les rails bon on a fait un
tas de trucs comme ça on ravitaillit
aussi quand il y avait un arrivage
tabac tout ça
[Musique]
voilà on n pas on n pas cadré ça sur
le sur le débarquement c'était c'est le
hasard qui a fait que c'était ce jour là
on voulait le faire tout de
suite plusieurs jours avec BR et puis la
douzaine qu'on était
là va falloir faire quelque chose ch
c'est quelque chose donc on avait dit on
va saboter les machines ainsi de suite
on viendra de
nuit on a mis à peu près une heure pour
mettre t
explosif et puis pour faire sauter tout
ça alors là où sont les diesel c'était
autre fois c'était le c'est là donc là
il y une dizaine de machines mon copain
c'est nous qui avons saboté C qui était
là pe plus C 8 ou 10 pe plus quelque
chose comme ça
celui il pleuvait il tombait des
albardes ah oui on se voyait pas à 4 m
45 m n'importe quel qui soit pas chemau
et encore du dépôt il Savit pas où il
savent pas où mettre les pieds hein de
la même manière qu'il a fallu que ça
soit des chemineaux qu' fassent parce
qu'on on sabote pas une machine comme ça
c'est pas un vélo hein machine vapeur
hein en plus pendant qu'on y était on en
s'amusant alors on avait
on a pris 3 kg de plastique là on est
mis sous le sous la plaque tournante
alors là ça ça ça bien faussé le le
milieu ça ça tournait mais tout carré ça
allit fort bien
après au total on a détruit 52
locomotives h machines outill et de
plaques
tournantes les Allemands n'ont rien dit
ils n ont pas inculpé ou ils on pas
supposé que parce que tout le monde dit
ou ça trop bien fait h trop bien fait ça
c'est un c'est commando ça commando
commando oh ça ça on connaît hein ça
c'est commando ça c'est
commando le maximum de qu'on peut faire
sur des machines c'est saboter c'est pas
ça suffit pour que il soit inutilisable
pendant de TR TR qu semaines depuis ce
temps aucun qu' voie n'a passé par ces
voislà il m'avait dit voilà Ruel m'a dit
voilà c'est réseau goalette est orienté
sur les
renseignements et donc si vous vous
engagez là je vous demande de ne pas
prendre d'engagement ailleurs que dans
ce que je vous commanderai de faire
maisnf c'était la couverture de travail
chef de district c'était celui qui était
mon grand chef dans la Résistance et
c'est lui qui dirigeait ces équipes là
et qui av dit voilà quen flamand est pas
là c'est que je l'emploie ailleurs ça
fait que je prévenais personne moi mon
nom de guerre c'était Florient pourquoi
Floriant parce qu'on m'avait dit voilà
euh on veut vous mettre un
nom qui commence par la même
syllabe que votre nom véritable pourquoi
parce que si on vous demande comment
vous appelez que vous ayez le temps le
quelques centièmes de secondes pour
répondre mais dire Florien et non pas
flamand c'est toujours Ruel qui me
donnait les ordres qui quelquefois
s'amener chez mes parents où je vivais
en disant il me faut des renseignement
sur le pon de Livron il faut à tout pris
le faire sauter ce truc alors vous
partez en vitesse
là-bas et là je prenais tout toutes les
coordonnées surous le regard
bienveillant des Allemands qui gardaient
le pon
c'était envoyé à Londres après et puis
alors ça je savais que en envoyant ces
ces renseignements là de 3 4 jours après
ça
tombait ça tombait
mais on pouvait rien
faire j'aurais eu de la famille dans le
coin j'aurais pas pu pu aller dire à la
famille ça va
[Musique]
tomber on a beaucoup parlé de dès qu'on
parle de chemin de fer de rissance on
parle toujours du sabotage de la voie
hein c'est le l'opération je dirais
classique standard moi je pense que les
cheminaux ont beaucoup plus résisté en
amont dans la chaîne pour qu'il y ait
une cible pour qu'un avion anglais aille
mitrailler un train allemand pour qu'on
aille saboter la voix à tel point
kilométrique à telle heure devant avant
un train allemand il faut être informé
je pense que globalement
fondamentalement les cheminau là de tout
poil de tout grade à tout niveau
instinctivement s'il pouvait informer
faire passer l'information vers alors
desérelais la résistance interne Londres
par radio et le lendemain arrivé l'avion
qui allait mitrailler le fameux train
mettons de
[Musique]
d'allemand
le mécanicien et le chauffeur sont les
premier exposé à la mitraillage de
l'avion anglais on se fait un peu rquir
et là-dessus ça a été très bien narré ce
côté cette difficulté de d'assumer le
train français ou allemand et de savoir
que ce train a été désigné à l'allié bon
mettezvous la pass mécanicien vous avez
d'un côté la mitraille allemande côté
l'avion de chasse anglais voilà voilà je
crois qu'on pe résumer que c'était pas
très ce n'était pas simple la position
entre prise entre deux feux et chaque
jour malgré les risques qu'ils font
courourir à leurs camarades mécaniciens
et chauffeurs des cheminaux n'hésite pas
à faire dérailler les trains obstruant
les voies principales complétant ainsi
l'action des
bombardements partir du moment où vous
aviez le faisceau qui était en grande
partie détruit que les ateliers étaient
aussi en grande partie parti détruit que
le dépôt était détruit également qu' y
avait de moins en moins de machine on
détruisait la capacité de transport ça
participé ça en avant enfin en avant
programmé dans le ce qu'on appelait le
plan vert le plan de débarquement dans
lesquel les chinau étaient appliqué d'e
d'une manière intensive voyez pour
essayer de retarder de toutes les
manières possibles et les le sabotage
tout ce que vous voulez le combat
les transport des troupes allemandes le
fond et autre il y a les gens qui ont
participé à plusieurs aspects de la
lutte et de la résistance contre
l'occupant mais il y en avait un qui
était peut-être à notre à notre avis pas
suffisamment encouragé c'était le
mouvement de masse ce que nous on appel
dans notre jargon le de masse rassembler
les gens même de ceux qui avaient
peur même des gens qui qui évitait de de
de s'engager trop mais qui était là
quand même pour à l'occasion manifester
leur hostilité contre l'occupant naasie
c'était ça le
l'objectif mission c'était la protection
des des des orateurs qui allaient
prendre la parole un peu partout pour
euh
disons inciter la population à réagir
avec plus de virulence contre l'occupant
le soir du 10 août 1944 on avait à peu
près 25 de nos ateliers qui avaient
débrillé sans compter les actions qui
avaient pu y avoir qui commençait à se
faire jour dans les gares et cetera et
c'est toute cette période à partir donc
du 10 août que se développé tous les
jours tous les jours ça pas été d'une
façon linéaire ça pas été uniforme et
tous les jours il s'est développé des
arrêts de travail dans ad mettons dans
tel ou tel dépôt dans tel ou tel gare
dans tel endroit et cetera si bien que
le 18 août
1944 la grève était générale au chin ver
il y av plus de train qui roulait
seulement ça pas étit simple cette grève
insurrectionnelle avec mon groupe j'ava
été chargé de garder une partie des
ateliers de wagon parce qu'on avait
distribué les tracles on avait été
informé tout le monde il fallait partir
fallait pas revenir l demain tout ça
mais qui avait peur qu'il sont revenus
et il a fallu les les virer c'est moment
de dire les [__] dehors leur dire tu
ne rentres pas parce que aujourd'hui
bien sûr on dit la grve du disout a été
une grève insurrectionnelle non la grve
de disout n'a pas été la révtionnelle
elle est devenue une
réventionnelle au moment où elle s'est
développée jusqu'au 18 à août et c'est à
partir du 18 à août où l'ensemble de la
corporation était en grève et le
mouvement s'est développé également dans
d'autres corporations hein ça s'est
développé dans tout le pays pour devenir
insurrectionnel voilà voilà le le schéma
en quelque sorte de ce qui s'est passé à
cette époque puis alors bon il y a eu
cette insurrection
qui a donné lieu après à tous les
sabotages que pouvez connaître qui sont
connu de tout le monde et puis bien sûr
les combat la libération de Paris des
environs tout ça que sur que c'est connu
tout le
[Musique]
monde ça y est tu es libre
les gens ne se rappent par ce que c'est
quelquefois la liberté ce que c'est
c'est c'est
extraordinaire
ah oui ça a été ça j'ai eu ça dans la
tête tout le trajet entre che chez mes
parents et puis la
gardeance c'est marrant parce que je me
retourneris je me retourner sur ce
parcours en disant disant bon ben ça y
est tu tu es tranquille
quoi le les allemand nous attaque à
chambla alors bagarre Chamblet et puis
je je suis blessé je prends 5
balles des éclats puis voilà c'est ma
deuxème blessure alors
mourant à l'hôpital où il me laissait
mourir tranquille
sur aller
quoi et puis ça c'est ma libération j'ai
rien vu moi hein mais là on sont venus
on pris d' on libéré d' avec les autres
quoi on libéré sa voie la Savoie
le la Drome jusqu'à la Drome la première
armée qui était bon des fois je m'engale
avec des gens de la première armée parce
que ils disent nous on est pas on a
dbqué puis après on est arrivé en Alsace
mais comment vous êtes arrivé en Alsace
il y avait plus d'allemand il y avait
plus rien comment vous avz av fait pour
arver hein parce que pour les gens de la
PR enfin des militaires de
carrière des fois je m'engueule avec eux
parce que moi je fais partie des anciens
combattants
bon nous on est des militaires par vous
je regrette vous es débarqué et puis
après comment vous êtes marié en Alsace
vous avez pas rencontré de résistance
pourquoi parce que nous on avait libéré
si nous on avait pas libéré ben vous ne
seriez pas arrivé en alace aussi vite he
bon non mais c'est comme ça bon
on s'est libérit tout seul c'était la
considération de l'armée pour les
résistances hein c'était le le moindre
qu'on peut dire c'est qu'il étaaiit pas
il nous considérait pas très bien parce
qu'on avait volé on avait pris leur
place on avait pris leur
place j'étais content mais on avait pas
fini notre travail
figurez-vous j'arrive pas à vous
répondre correctement à à la question
c'est
que nous
Chemino évidemment notre lo notreé de
travail était
paralysé mais il a fallu qu'on défend
contre la
population par bien sûr dans nos dépôts
il y avait le
charbon et il a fallu que j'ai pris la
parole pour expliquer aux gens qu'il ne
fallait pas prendre le charbon parce
qu'on en aurait besoin vous mettre dans
le locomotif pour aller en charercher
que s'il prenait le charbon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pu vous avez la déportation des Juifs
vousz déportation en même temps des des
communistes qui étaient arrêtés
vousortation des des résistants alors
qui se situait à partir de différents
centres alors soit des centrales où vous
était déjà euh disons emprisonné soit
dans des des centres vous étiez
regroupés drancis pour les pour les
Juifs et compiène pour les résistants
bon à partir de là les les équipes qui
faisaient C TR là savaient ce qu'ils
emmenaient enfin ce qu'ils emmenaient
c'est une sale expression c'est pas je
la retire ils savaient qui nous
emmenaient bon mais
comment faire pour y déroger mais il
fallait bien consuivre nous étions
entreprise
d'État lequel allait arrêter le train le
cheminau tout seul sur sa locomotive il
pouvait
pas les SS étaient là partout l'armée
allemande était là partout et les SS en
plus mais dire que les cheminau en tant
que tel pouvait dire bah non moi je fais
pas le train oui ben il vous Metz au
poteau vous fusz puis après ils en
prenaient d'autres ben arrivé au 10e le
11e il faisait les est pas alors ceux
qui disent bah non il fait les pas le
faire oui moi je les aime bien ces
gens-là mais j'aurais aimé qu'ils se
trouve dans ces conditions là on on voit
des déportés aujourd'hui en améric ça se
pass he qui porte plainte contre la SNCF
B qu'est-ce qu'il fallait faire c'était
pas forcément toujours le même dépôt qui
conduisait les mêmes et comment plus ça
se faisait par étape par que une une
équipe vapeur
fa 150 à 200 km maximum avec sa machine
P on la rentrée la coupé on en mettait
une autre avec une autre équipe qui
allait un autre plus loin cétait pas
quand on vient nous dire que équipe de
conduiteen des portés jusqu'à auchchwitz
non mais on rêve c'est qu'on va auchwiz
c'est quand même pas la porte à côté
c'est quand même en Pologne vous voyez
puis V saint-j all est d' vous en
Pologne ils ont jamais mis du charbon
dans le PO il sa pas ce que c'est que de
manier l'appelle mais c'est un vrai
semblable d qu'on est paril mexcusz mon
expression mais c'est la seule qui
convient à mon avis voyez B on
savaitortations mais on savait pas où
ils allaient l'istoire des Juifs tout ça
on l' su qu'après bon on savait qu'il y
avait quelque chose mais on savait pas
l'ampleur on ne connaissait pas
l'ampleur on l' su qu'à la
libération
en parlant de plus malin faut pas dire
quand on a fait toutes ces opérations là
celllà puis les autres on eu souvent la
fusse ou ce qui prouve qu'on était à peu
près normal quoi j'avais 17 ans et demi
vous voyez j'étais le plus jeune et le
plus vieux avais 19 ans voyez je su une
seule survivant de mon groupe j'étais
blissé deux fois au combat j'ai vu
partir à la
[Musique]
mort des gens carrément quoi moi je
serais
mais je évidemment je vous savez bien
que on peut pas qu'on batte sans qu'il a
des des périodes où on soit pris on soit
presque pris on soit hein je suis tombé
dans une embuscade le hasard plus que je
m'en sorte bon tout B ces périodeslà ce
sont des périodes qui sont difficiles
j'avais fait mais je savais que
j'étais j'étais foutu quoi je je savais
que je je pensais pas m'en sortir puis
en fin de compte P il a il y a un trou
pour passer où on passe mais celui qui a
pas de morale il est mort vous le
comprenez ça celui que bon qui se
dégonfle il est mort si demain il avait
Le Pen pouvoir qui veulent remplacer
Hitler
repartira prendra le Maqui je resterai
pas ici celu-ci je serait sûr d'être
Bendu 3 jours
après
moi la liberté moi c'est majuscule c'est
pas n'importe quoi Z la liberté faut la
conquérir et quand on a faut la garder
c'est pour le plus simple
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voyez
[Applaudissements]